[Music]
tattoos for me one of the reason I
started to get them is because when I
was in prison when you go to prison they
they completely strip you of an identity
you know you don't even have a name
anymore you're given a number my number
was SK 931 that means I was the 930
first person sentenced to death in
Arkansas to the state of Arkansas I was
not damien echols I was inmate SK 931
they take your clothes they take your
name there were even times when I was
shackled to a chair and had my head
shaved against my will just to make you
look like every other prison prisoner in
the prison you know there's they don't
want any form of identity any form of
humanity so I learned that pretty much
everything can be stripped away from you
except your skin that was why I started
tattooing things that were meaningful to
me bonds I shared with other people you
know friends anyone from Johnny Depp and
Peter Jackson we've got tattooed
together too just people that were
friends of mine in the tattoo shop you
know it's like if you have a photograph
you can lose that photograph it can be
torn up it can be you know disintegrate
through time but whenever you carry
something on your body it's almost like
you have a suit of armor made out of the
things that are meaningful to you so a
lot of the things I have on me were not
only things that I shared with friends
like representative bonds that I had
with other people but I started to also
use talismans sigils what talismans are
we were talking about thought-forms
while ago well some things are really
hard to visualize if you want to put
energy into manifesting something you
know say for example happiness so you
don't know what will make you happy you
just know that you're not happy at this
particular time in your life you're not
happy with your job but you don't know
what job would make you happy you're not
happy in your relationship and you don't
know exactly what sort of relationship
you want to be in that would bring
happiness you can use a talisman or a
sigil to take a concept like happiness
and break it down into a symbolic form
that will bypass the conscious mind and
can be fired directly into the
subconscious because it just looks like
a squiggly line for the most
it looks like an alphabet that your
conscious mind doesn't read so what
bypasses all of the thought processes
goes deep into your unconscious psyche
and can then work in whatever way it
works down there you know I don't know
how some of this stuff works I just know
it does work if you break it down into
just a symbol and then put the energy
put the Chi into that symbol you can
manifest something that you may not
necessarily be able to picture you know
like happiness or protection or love I
even have one of my favorite ones is
probably the one on the side of my neck
and what it is is a talisman that
represents New York City because to me
this is home the second I landed here
the second I stepped off the plane I
knew this was the place I wanted to live
and this was a place I wanted to die I
want to be buried here so and like I
said earlier if you react to something
if you interact with something as if
there's an intelligence behind it it
will react to you in the same way so you
can do the same thing with not only
concepts but places you know we think of
for some reason people have come to
think of natural places or or wooded
areas or deserts or whatever as being
somehow more sacred or more holy than
urban environments and that's not true
at all you know everything is made out
of the same divine substance so either
everything and every place is sacred or
none of them are for me I choose to
approach life as if they all are so if
you interact with New York City as if
there is an intelligence behind it the
same way the Romans did the same way the
Greeks did then it will behave towards
you the same way so I will do things
like you know some people in different
traditions like say Native American
shamanism will interact with spirits of
animals for me it's more along the lines
of spirits of particular trains you know
you burn blue candles to communicate and
link yourself to the spirit of the sea
train or the a train then it will
respond to you as if there is an
intelligence behind it so the tattoo on
my neck what I wanted to do was sort of
enshrine New York City the spirit of
this place sort of ask for its blessing
as for its favor and
go about day-to-day life here
[Music]